philosophy for our times is brought to
you in partnership with the new college
of the humanities a university level
college offering undergraduate and
postgraduate degrees in the heart of
London NCH pride themselves on offering
unprecedented access to a world-class
academic faculty philosophy students of
the college are taught by some of the
foremost scholars in the field a
one-to-one tutorials create a
personalized teaching experience choose
your major and minor for a unique
combined honours degree and study the
nch diploma to widen your appreciation
of the world in ways you never thought
of before go to NC h london dot a c dot
uk' for more information think better
think NC h hello and welcome to
philosophy for our times the podcast
which brings you the world's leading
thinkers to debate today's biggest ideas
most of us think that when lightning
strikes or waves crash that they do so
even if we're not there to see them this
week our speakers question our role in
reality does the field of quantum
physics mean we need to radically
rethink our idea of objective reality
according to quantum mechanics the
observer is critical to reality
Heisenberg even went so far as to say
that in contemporary physics objective
reality has evaporated so should we
accept the objective reality has
evaporated is reality nothing more than
an illusion or did Heisenberg and most
of quantum mechanics get it wrong it's
the world independent of the observer if
so what does this mean for free well our
world-famous panel this week our Nobel
prize-winning Jared tough constructor
theorist Chiara maleta
an Oxford quantum physicist Christopher
Timpson let us know what you thought
this episode and where you think our
role in reality is by tweeting us at IFE
please do head over to iTunes to give us
a rating and review as we'd love to know
what you think back now to David Malone
who hosts this week's episode
Griss would you like to start with
telling us whether REM BLTs there with a
thank you David yes I would take the
question here and is reality necessary
to mean something like to what extent do
we as individuals people like us or
creatures like us with relevant
complexity similar to our own so what
extent are we free agents able to affect
the course of goings-on in nature or
perhaps even help constitute the course
of goings-on in nature versus everything
being fixed up from time immemorial in
intensity detailed physical laws which
constrain goings-on now with the
question of whether and to what extent
we play an active role in constructing
reality today I want to argue yes I want
to take the view of a particular
approach to physics to quantum physics
called quantum Bayesian ism or cubism
for short and try and help explain to
you how Cubist's quantum basins contract
learning into Cubist's q bist and how
the Cubist's would answer positively the
question do we play an active role in
constructing reality now so so far as
that is the case that reality is not
necessary we are doing something
interesting and interestingly different
from how normal physics how classical
physics would allow us to be doing but
with the question of constructing I want
to lay down some distinctions to begin
with we might find helpful as we go
through so it seems to me that there are
these three different notions of
constructing reality we ought to be
interested in here maybe there are more
but at least these three will be useful
to bear in mind so I think we need to
distinguish between causal constructing
a reality between constitutive
constructing of reality and finally
conceptual construction of reality so
the the first of these the causal
construction of reality is a very
humdrum notion that's the way in which
any object which is capable of doing
things makes a difference the world in
virtue of its being now so in the same
way that one might construct a house by
moving around bricks and mortar and
glass and cement and so on one can
construct reality by doing things like
moving around
bricks and mortar and glass and cement
so it's just the humble idea of our
making or if they're being causal
differences in the world in virtual
certain objects being there is that's
quite a humble notion constitutive
construction of reality is a different
notion a more metaphysical one if you
will and it's the idea there being some
kind of metaphysical dependence between
kinds of objects so there might be as
something which is causally independent
of me something which I haven't myself
made but nonetheless which exists and
there's a question of whether or not it
such as this table which I didn't make
does this table exist independently of
me that's a constitutive notion
metaphysical notion and finally
conceptual construction that's to do
with our description of the world to
what extent to the concepts that we
deploy in physics or anything else to
what extent are they responsive to a way
that the world is independent of any
process of concept construction about it
any process of the activities of
representing beings now according to the
Cubist's essentially what the action is
on the causal construction of reality
and importantly the difference here from
classical physics is that in classical
physics typically we thought that
insofar as we ourselves as observers
have any role in causally constructing
reality it's a derivative one that's
derived from the completely detailed
completely fixed deterministic laws of
the universe that have existed forever
or retained forever and our activities
are merely consequences of initial
conditions of the universe and the
changeless laws the Cubist's would have
it that this is wrong
there may exist emergent higher-level
generalizations which describe our
goings on but at the fundamental
microscopic level there simply aren't
any laws there and that crucially for
the quantum Asian's opens up the
possibility of ourselves as agents doing
things autonomously ourselves in the
world in a way which isn't arrived from
the laws of nature and I have to stop
you there thank you um Joe would you
like to go next room do we play an
active role in constructing reality I
would like to give a little bit of a
perspective of the Croesus explanation
about all of these different ways of
thinking about this question a
perspective on how a physicist would
would would consider this question about
reality so
it's a bit like you know you face with a
tiger the target shows up and and yeah
you of course you could wonder is this
real but you don't want to take a chance
and so it's better to think fast and and
find the problem you have solution to
the problem so try to get out of the way
and and so likewise in in physics the
way I feel about this question is that
really it seems we are facing problems
all the time
and these problems basically gaps in in
this conceptual understanding that Chris
was mentioning of reality and we're
trying to solve them and so in that
sense I think we are constructing
something for instance we were wondering
at some point in the past
how come it looks like stars are moving
in the sky and Sun looks like moving in
the sky etc and we were trying to feed
that into our understanding that maybe
the earth was was was at the center of
everything and that didn't work at some
point so that was a problems like the
tiger so the question of whether reality
is really out there is somehow secondary
in this context because what we seem to
be worried about is how to solve
problems and the solutions that we come
up for these problems are these theories
that we have about reality quantum
theory is an example there are lots of
others and these theories are something
that we construct so this is kind of
every time someone comes up with a new
theory there's new knowledge in the
world and this is something that we use
in order to make tentative progress and
I think this is for those who like
philosophy this is a bit of the view of
karl popper's now this is possibly I
think the most honest and compatible
view of reality that I see from the
point of view of all physics so that's
that's my that's my take on on this
question okay Darren what do you think
yes I like to state my answer to the
first question right away I say of
course not
reality is it's one of the great
accomplishments of science in general
that we have discovered how the reality
around us
chillie can be explained and how things
behave according to laws of nature but
now of course you have quantum mechanics
and quantum mechanics seems at first
sight to put everything upside down and
say to say that there's vagueness and so
on but I think you have to make a very
clear distinction not about vagueness of
the world that they are seeing around us
and the vagueness in our way of
describing this world so physicists
haven't yet done their job completely
they've only found a partial solution to
the question why are the laws of physics
away the eye on what's happening the
answer is we don't know but the best we
can do is make predictions and our
predictions are they if we you see every
day the weather forecast in television
or whatever you see that they have
certain percent chance of rain here
those hundred percent chance of rain
normally they say any certain chances of
rain chance of sunshine and so on we are
unsure because our theories I imperfect
of course the ideal universe is far too
complex to say things anything better
than that but now I come to a very
important point I say if you believe
that the world is realistic that the
laws of nature turn only about real
things happening you have to take that
all the way because whenever you have
discussions about the subject very often
people say yes but don't we have free
will to do this and free will to do that
when we measure things as soon as you
say that you say wait a minute free will
what free will free will is also
determined by deterministic laws of
nature we don't know yours laws of
course we don't we are human we have all
our limitations we can't predict how
fast you are breathing this moment but
it's all fixed by by laws of nature and
we should find our task as physicist it
should be to figure out what these laws
are as accurately as we can today's most
accurate theory is called quantum
mechanics so yes I'm very sorry but
every now and then you can't predict
things with certainty that's because our
models are failing because
all are very good and in practice the
predictions we can make are fantastic
but they're not perfect so that you have
to take into account then the crash of
cubits theory the question why we even
have cubits well it just sawed tells us
how bad our understanding is we can
create vagueness in a very complicated
way and this complicated vagueness is
called entanglement even that can happen
which means that we still have a long
way to go to understand those
deterministic laws in fact I think we
are being misled by the fantastic
features of mathematics
our world is seems to describe the
fantastic mathematical equations
mathematicians can handle this kind of
uncertainty they call these non
commuting numbers and not only that in
mathematics we can describe and tango
States very very well and also
mathematics tells us there's a fantastic
symmetry in this world our problem is
the seventh is much too large for
instance particles can only sit in
certain orientations they can only an
electron can only have two orientations
in this world that is very strange
because you would think that you could
hope to locate an electron any way you
like and you get another rotation how
come the particles can only have two
orientations
well that's called symmetry there is
rotation invariance in the world which
is to property of mathematics but it is
not a true property of those realistic
states which we eventually want to
describe again this means there is lots
of work to be done why is this so
important this question because in the
Copenhagen discussions people had at a
time the outcome discussion was don't
ask such silly questions because you
cannot check it experimentally that is
true but that's not a good argument
because you can still still to
investigate a realism is very important
for our question of model building our
models of the the world today I
imperfect that's why they come to
mechanical but to improve that we need
to have some leads and one of the leads
that we want to use is suppose the world
is completely realistic what would that
do to the more
we have today how can we improve our
understanding okay so um I think it's
worth just passing a little bit more on
the the role of the observer because
classically what everyone gets taught is
that at the macro level you sit on the
outside of events you don't have any
effect if the table falls off it's not
because you've thought about it it just
happened
whereas at the quantum level that has
always appeared to be this the observer
has an effect that when the observer
observes the cat's either dead or alive
but was possibly both up until then are
we are we saying that that view which
goes which is what turned physics upside
down when it happened that we now say no
it's it that's completely wrong that
there is no magical cat which might be
led where it might be alive and you are
we saying that that's wrong now I think
that's where Jared wants to take him yes
Jared totally does not sure but so let's
press that question a bit further so on
the one hand you might say yes whatever
theories we have at a given time even if
there are a best established theories
the best we're working with you know
perhaps there's some successor theory
which will have some other features than
the current theory we're looking at so
that's one thing that we're being urged
to look at my Jared and it could be that
in whatever the success of theory is
it's business as normal with regards to
the status of the observer visa via the
rest of reality something like a return
to classical physics well maybe but the
question is on what basis do we make
that judgment
and it doesn't seem to me that things
need be like that maybe it'd be nice if
there so but maybe maybe we can actually
be more excited by what if you look at
the content of many general claims
rotate to hold given quantum mechanics
is predictive success that in fact a
more natural thing to think is that
there isn't any more fundamental
microscopically non very complete theory
to behaves what do I mean by that we
have the process of looking at the
general claims made by quantum mechanics
are looking at the confirmed
experimental predictions formulating
again
or general theoretical scheme in which
these can be embedded and explained and
then drawing conclusions about what
further kinds of theories could possibly
produce the results that we've seen in
experiments these are called no-go
theorems and they're go experience in
quantum theory but you're trying to pin
down not features of quantum mechanics
itself but features of what the world
itself needs to be like in virtue of the
predictions of quantum mechanics being
confirmed experimentally and it seems to
me that the output of these theoretical
and experimental results is in many ways
very naturally explained by saying there
isn't a fundamental complete completion
there isn't a fundamental set of laws at
the microscopic level describing
everything which behave in much the way
that physics tradition has taken it to
do and what's the problem with that so I
want to ask you Jared why the insistence
for for this atavistic notion of the
underlying physics well I find that
alternatives are much worse so I think
the best of all possible worlds that I
can imagine would be a completely
deterministic one and once you say party
deterministic then you fail completely
when you say okay deterministic but in
Bell's famous Gedanken experiment Bob
and Alice still have the free will to
choose their orientations then I said
wait a minute now you're violating
something and now you're putting
yourself in a difficult position and if
you look very carefully at the
mathematics I tame that Bell didn't have
his definition of causality correct
so causality to him means that the
future will not affect the past but of
the past will affect the future that
sounds reasonable but it isn't in our
models yes but in the world as soon as
you change anything in the present you
must have had that preceded by change in
the past otherwise a change couldn't
have happened
so the problem the bellows was
struggling with was that he didn't want
to change the past but it did evolve
change the decisions that Bob and others
make to measure something that is
forbidden and that itself is a very
strange thing that that makes it very
hard for us to make models which show
that
so Belle thought because his arguments
does modify impossible and I can know we
haven't searched hard enough but I don't
think they're impossible so hey you
wanted to say that quantum mechanics may
have appeared to its discoverers and
generation of science afterwards to
involve this sort of randomness if you
like but you're saying they just need to
peel back that layer and underneath
there will be some rules which are
deterministic which like rules up here
you have to actively search for that if
you don't do that you'll never you know
you never do such a thing for instance
you're you get string theories which
things he is also fundamentally quantum
mechanical so this is why I have my
doubts also for string theories well
you're not there yet now are you are you
finding with this theory force well
there yeah well there are lots of things
to say so the one important thing is
that we mentioned you're observers now
usually there is this capital letter O
in front of observer which is kind of
perhaps misleading in the sense that as
far as I understand quantum theory is
very democratic in regard to observers
that means that basically if you just
consider what quantum theory tells you
about an electron interacting with
another electron you can in a way
describe in the same way the way an
observer such as a macroscopic observer
such as you for instance interacts with
a measuring instrument which is also
microscopic which then interacts with
something that's less microscopic and
less macroscopic etc etc up to the point
where you hit the electron so I'm noting
in agreement with this this view that
that kind of singles out observers as as
special entities because it seems to me
that unless you add some postulates on
top of quantum theory itself there isn't
any such distinction within the theory
and it's actually the beauty of the
theory because it leads us to think of
what would happen if an observer such as
you were to be superposed across
different state of for example
consciousness or things like that of
course we can't do that now but it's a
nice thought
and it would be interesting to consider
that I just wanted to say that therefore
when we talk about observers we have to
probably with three of us have different
views about what that means and in my
case I don't regard an observer as an
entity which is that different from an
electron which interacts with some other
system can I ask you because you you've
raised the observer as being important
surely quantum mechanical things were
happening long before humans evolved or
were cats before we came along always
not quite sure if they were alive or
dead it goes good so I mean this is this
is an excellent way of probing exactly
this kind of question about the role of
the observer and so when I was stating
the kind of view the Cubist view that I
want to explore today I did allow that
there could be low-light claims
generalizations about macroscopic kinds
of objects so it's only really when you
sink down that quantum effects are
becoming very salient that you begin to
lose the laws that you lose the law like
structure underpinning things and you're
left with a sea of entities having
causal powers modal powers abilities
dispositions to do things but not
falling under any well-organized set of
physical laws and that's consistent with
all the macroscopic stuff dinosaurs and
all the rest of it having existed stars
having existed for an awfully long time
because the business as usual for large
stuff they're surprised in this approach
is that it's not business as usual when
you look at this small stuff of which
the large stuff is supposed to be made
so we can completely recover our
intuitions about what the structure of
the past was like insofar as we ought to
have determinate intuitions there namely
at the level of the things which are
roughly familiar big very big stuff but
also fairly small stuff so you should
probably able to get most of biology to
come out if you ignore the details about
how chemical bonding works thank you for
that I feel reassured why is it that
this theory which everyone has signed up
to for better part of a century none of
everyone accepts it but nobody had
nobody shares the same fear we've got
many worlds we've got hidden variables
we've got don't ask why is that
I mean it's if if any other theory had
wildly different interpretations humble
biologists like us would say where you
don't have a theory but you will think
you do there are different ways of
interpreting the theory so there are
you've got the mathematical framework
and then you're asking yourself how are
we to understand this what's the world
like if this is a good mathematical
description of it there's a good deal of
the content of the theory which is
insensitive to what particular
philosophy if you like you take to it
and that's most of what you need for
deploying the theory in most
experimental situations not all of them
one of the things that's slightly
strange about the debate with quantum
theory is that we forget how weird
classical physics is like classical
physics is supposed to be non weird
classical physics is deeply deeply weird
and it's an excellent education so I
think you know what is a point particle
is no such thing as a point particle
yeah that's supposed to be what
Newtonian physics is about is it isn't
actually the idea of a point particle
literally incoherent and and it
collapses in Newtonian physics or and
Maxwell you in physics if you push it
too hard so these kinds of questions
arrive in any bits of physics in fact in
many bits of science more generally you
can always ask what really what's going
on here as well as having a day-to-day
practice of deploying the theory in very
skilled ways and it's just that we
haven't had a successor theory in the
last 100 years which has made us stop
asking these kinds of questions about
quantum theory and it's a theory where
it's hard to push it to levels where
it's easy to see where some of these
different philosophical points of view
would make an experimental difference so
such things are possible and do exist
but it's an experimental challenge some
are very distant challenges some more
nearby to to push things into a realm
where we can look at that so this is
this is richness rather than poverty of
understanding yeah I was just wanted to
say that the I think one of the reasons
why this is happening is that all of the
existing interpretations agree on what
is accessing accessible through
experiments at this time so you know
what what our technology can
experimentally probe the predictions of
all these there is ways of looking at
quantum theory are the same and they
ought to be the same because otherwise
it would not be quantum theory it would
be a different theory
our proposals for a different theory so
there are these models are called
collapse models where the idea is that
there is a specific scale at which
quantum theory fails so those can be
tested against quantum theory and you
know we are getting closer and closer to
testing them at larger and larger scales
however as far as interpretations go
given that their interpretations can be
tested with respect to one another so
that's possibly one of the reasons why
this is happening and it's connected to
a particular feature of the theory which
is that unlike classical physics and as
perhaps while we're not wondering about
classical physics as much unlike
classical physics well control theory
says is that there are features of a
physical system that can be accessed
just by looking at it once so what you
can do is that you can prepare systems
lots of copies in the same state and do
lots of experiments the same to figure
out what's going on and get a an overall
picture and a complete picture but if
you just limit yourself to single
measurements on a single system you can
only get some partial information so
there are some empirically inaccessible
features and those are the ones about
which interpretations differ and as far
as I'm concerned I think there was only
one interpretation which is many words
but that's just me really there are many
worlds personal well I think that's the
one that makes the most sense it doesn't
make any sense to me
but then well yeah because the others
are even worse I have to go with what is
that the argument for democracy it
doesn't work bit still better than
others do you you obviously don't go for
the many words absolutely not why why
not why I was thinking about the
previous question about why there are so
many interpretations and I think the
answer is that the actually correct
interpretation is very difficult so
Einstein was focused on to say that the
dear God is very refined but not
malicious in total mechanics may be very
close should be an exception to this
that the truth is very difficult to to
fathom whereas it's much easier to
to make some simplifications which are
actually wrong I had an uncle and famous
theatrical physicist in Holland you
should say that about many things has
only one tooth and there are many lies
so in a democratic world the live always
win and he was not very optimistic about
humanity's future but but I think it
holds it quantum mechanic said there's
always something wrong with whoever
comes in the interpretation that there
is not like like saying that simple
reality and that's it and that's the
only one left to me where I can't say
there's something obviously wrong with
it right but I mean I'm thinking about
it saying that I'm Stein some some
people have said to me I just and didn't
leave from quantum mechanics that seems
to be silly I think what he said was
quantum mechanics is obviously true I
just don't think your theories are right
so would he be on your side yeah
would he be closer to Jarrod's right he
just felt that the theory as Heisenberg
and Bohr came up with it was just
obviously not right well it was
predictively
right but he felt that it didn't have
the overall correct theoretical shape
and he was interested in something like
a hidden variable kind of completion but
not of a an ordinary kind okay you can't
say hidden variable without telling
people so this is one of the various
interrupts it is it fair to say that
hidden variables is making a comeback
because it is a matter a fashion I mean
in fashion for us as flared trousers and
kipper ties for this lot its many worlds
or hidden variables or is it is hidden
variables coming back and can you tell
them what it is I think it's so you use
the word hidden variables right at the
beginning when I was explaining what it
was so I'm just following you leave
right so the idea of a so-called hidden
variable is that if you take the normal
mathematical descriptions in quantum
mechanics it doesn't seem to tell you
all of the things you think there might
be said about how the world is and the
idea is there might be some actual
variables in the world which we're not
seeing
hence hidden which do fill fill in all
the details so there's no vagueness
perhaps because in fact there's there is
a more specific description that's going
on underneath it's just one that we're
ignorant of so I think it's fair to say
that in some ways dads and preferred
option for a surpassing or competing
quantum theory
would be a species of hidden variable
theory but one which is relaxed about
backwards influence in time but in terms
of making a comeback or think with all
of these interpretations collapse hidden
variables were actually there are
probably increasing numbers of adherents
of all of them because we're actually
understanding what's involved of them in
them better and in some ways it's quite
good to have a plurality of views you've
got serious people seriously developing
them in both the hidden variables
program and collapse programs you've got
genuine physics to do as well as just
philosophy so you actually have to show
how these things could be completed in
various ways to work in high-energy
physics and so on in particle physics
and whether or not ultimately they're
successful is probably down to whether
or not you can get those kinds of models
to work to build so it's basically a
kind of a physics question not a
philosophy question but I think there's
more of everything and that's truly a
good thing it surely can I can move on
to the third theme which is what would
be the consequence if the hidden
variables is right or if if the collapse
is right does it make a difference in
how we see the world and how we feel we
work in it I mean is it just a matter of
free will or do other things come and go
I think it's absolutely so then one
objection half against hidden variable
theory is its name I don't think it's
the extra variables are hidden they are
just difficult to see and because 99.9
percent or more of this world is hidden
because we can think of particles
accelerating to much higher energies
than we can ever make and the quantum
states here we'll be in a party hidden
but we have no access to that kind of
information so these are variables to
which we have no access today but it
doesn't mean that they're hidden for any
fundamental reason other than saying we
cannot see them because our experiments
are not good enough to do that but then
in the very end I think if we keep this
in mind the theory that that could be
such a thing as hidden variables let's
try to make models which take them into
account in a very natural way then I
think that will be a big advantage and
we have some leads to hold on to to make
our next best series for
for a reality well I still want to push
on this question of so that we can all
understand does the does what we how we
think world work change fundamentally if
you're right I mean does do we all have
to go there's no such thing as free
wheel or I think the answer is yes not
so much that that you now dealing with
quantum mechanics and and and that the
world of the atoms and the fundamental
particles and the photons will be any
difference no it will be the same world
you'd be talking about but in the very
end you'll have an explanation that's
completely natural in terms of ordinary
physical processes which do not know
anything else quantum mechanics this is
fish I have is that ultimately the laws
of nature that this describes some sort
of theory of everything would be a
laws of nature where the word no birds
face the word quantum mechanics doesn't
occur but in working out in creation see
now what is the consequence of this
theory for our daily lives we have to
switch on quantum mechanics not as as a
belief but as a mathematical procedure
mathematicians use such procedures or
very long long ago so they are working
with vectors all the time for them it's
very ordinary to do so for physics we
also want to interpret what these
factors mean am i saying my claim is
they mean nothing they mean they display
your ignorance but it's much better
because look at that 10 to the 4 to a 10
to the 80 or something protons in the
universe who can well I like how can you
ever think that we can control and
understand every single one of them of
course we don't so we have to make all
sorts of approximations which are
statistical of nature and the best
application will then discovery is
called quantum mechanics ok can either
do either of you two feel like rescuing
our because if I've understood you right
we would have to say we think we have
something like free will but it's not
true
so we're creatures who are automatons in
some respect but programmed think they
have free will
it's that rather of YouTube in a rescue
us from this because I don't fancy that
really
but I'm afraid the question of freewill
is actually way above our heads in the
sense that some of you will pay great no
I mean the no what I meant is that the
so in any of these interpretations many
wells even collapse there is just one at
least in the case of collapse there's
just one path that the universe goes
through so even though if you even if
you relaxed this hidden variable idea
and you go in to the collapse
interpretation what happens he said the
you know the history of the universe can
be collected into a sequence of such
collapses but just one trajectory and
even though there is some stochasticity
in it that doesn't mean that necessary
that there is space for your freewill so
that also doesn't necessarily rescue
freewill and that's one of the reasons
you might want to come over to the
Cubist side of things because they say
it's a different look so that there's
enough structure and goings on that you
can put your cup on the table and not
fall through but there isn't an
underlying set of laws which are
determining what you're doing
so in Cubism I mean if one's worried
about the questions of compatibility
between determinism and freewill or even
between the obtaining of physical law
and free will then cubism gives you a
robust way of getting out of it because
you like many other objects in the world
are autonomous and the possessors of
causal power and you can make a
difference and you're not just arriving
that difference making from the laws and
initial conditions so there is genuine
scope here for something different is
there a is there a cost to that if I
sign up to that because that sounds
great I get to decide where I go on
holiday wasn't predetermined but do I
then have to sign up for that if I close
my eyes you will disappear no I mean
that's a good point right so this comes
back to the causal constitutive business
I mentioned earlier so it's not the case
that other things in the world their
essence if you will owe their existence
better is constituted by engagement with
me that's not part of the that the
Cubist picture is rather that and you've
got a something which has its capacities
and powers you go to something else me
maybe which has got its capacities and
powers they bump into each other and
react in a certain kind of way which
isn't governed by any detailed law at
the microscopic level but this thing
still exists this thing still exists
and you will still exist if I close my
eyes and stuff my ears you'll be glad to
say so it's not a solid sis kind of
program just the certs that there are
fewer physical laws than you thought
there are and the physical laws there
are go into less detail than you thought
errors I think that sounded good please
there's just one thing to say that that
it's nice to know that both the collapse
view and the hidden variable view are
somehow conservative views in the sense
that they try to rescue this classical
picture of the world which is so dear to
us because that's what we see directly
and the reason why I actually have like
many worlds is that it's actually the
genuinely revolutionary a new thing in
quantum mechanics so there is a
different come from from the one of its
just heard about where physics are
betting that the next theory is going to
be even more wild than quantum theory
and it's gonna surprise us in even more
ways so most of these features that
quantum theory can power such as you
know even quantum computing and so on
depend from these other wild features
that more conservative ways of looking
at quantum theory would like to reduce
to some classic ality and I would like
that not to be the case I would actually
like to be that the quantum theory is as
well as it seems to be I'm hoping also
to search for the next year is informed
by this view and that the next year is
gonna be even wilder and I think that's
a great place to end i I know we've only
scratched the surface
I just wanna mention that are also
loopholes in the theorems well it just
remains for me to point out the last
loophole which you can close which if
you'd help me to thank our panelists
please thank you for listening to this
week's episode of philosophy for our
times this podcast is brought to you by
the Institute of Art and ideas it was
hosted by me Anna Carey and I guess this
week with Jared tuft Chiara maletto and
Christopher Timpson as ever we'd love to
hear what you thought so please do head
up to iTunes and leave us a review and a
rating
subscribe today to make sure you never
miss any of our episodes and of course
tune in next week for more debates and
interviews from the world's leading
thinkers on today's biggest ideas for
more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the institute of arts
and ideas at iai TV
you